اذا ميدانيا فيما يخص المعارك واخر
التطورات على الجبهات لاسيما الشرقيه منها
اعلن عن الجيش الروسي مشاهدينا ان قوته
الناريه تقضي على الدفاعات الاوكرانيه على
اكثر من جبهه سابدا بمبخوت حيث تحاول
القوات الاوكرانيه هنا او او عفوا القوات
الروسيه كانت قد حاولت بهذه النقطه تحديدا
بالتطويق المنطقه بعد السيطره على سوليدار
فالقامت اذن بتطويق بعد السيطره على
فوليدار قامت القوات الاوكرانيه الروسيه
همم تطبيق
من جبهات عده ومحاوله السيطره على هذه
المدينه التي تعتبر مدينه استراتيجيه بهذه
الحرب وهو طبعا ما اثار حفيظه الغرب
الاونه الاخيره وادى الى ارسال دبابات
ومساعدات غربيه الى هذه المنطقه الى ضخمه
تحديدا من باخ موت انت الى دنيا بالدنياسك
ايضا هناك معارك داريه همم تجري بهذه
الاثناء في محيط دونياس حيث تكثف القوات
الروسيه هجماتها وايضا تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه احراز همم يعني تفوق على الارض
وتقدم على الارض ولكن طبعا كما هو معلوم
القوات الاوكرانيه تتفوق على الروسيه
بعدد الجنود هنا وايضا بالاسلحه والمعدات
الحربيه من انظمه دفاع من طائرات وغيره
بهذه المنطقه هناك معارك ايضا تدور في
مارينكا هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه هناك همم محاوله للقوات
الاوكرانيه باحراس تقدم فيها وايضا القوات
الروسيه هنا تحكم السيطره على شبهات عدى
بهذه المنطقه حيث هناك يعني معركه حاميه
في هذه المناطق طبعا مشاهدينا بموازات هذه
الصوره هناك الصوره في زابوريجيا حيث
محاوله روسيه باحكام السيطره على المنطقه
كامله وايضا بحسب مراسلينا هناك هناك
محاوله روسيه
لاستحداث نقاط ثابته واستقدام حوالي
40,000 مقاتل لاحراس تقدم بهذه المنطقه
التي تعتبر ايضا استراتيجيه بموازازات كل
الصوره على الارض القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه يعني توقع همم
ضحايا همم باتحدث هنا من الجانبين وايضا
هناك خسائر بالعتاد بالدبابات بالصواريخ
وبالانظمه الدفاع تحاول القوتين يعني
باحداث خسائر بالغه عند الطرفين اذا هذه
هي كانت الصوره
اوكرانيا الموريتانيه طبعا
[موسيقى]